there's been a super interesting turn of
events in the last
48 hours or so where donald trump has
called fox news
fake news at a recent event and after
day one of the dnc
multiple fox news anchors actually
heaped praise upon michelle obama for
her speech which was a good speech
so let's not read into this more than
what it is but i do think there's an
interesting discussion here here's
donald trump in wisconsin this week
calling fox news fake news
but we're doing great coming back we're
coming back and our numbers are better
than
almost all countries i will tell you
that
despite what you hear look at all of
them up there scott look at all of that
fake news it's
unbelievable unfortunately fox has
become fake news too i don't know what
happens to these people right
do you agree and then continuing the
reversals
behavior that is opposite what we would
expect what we've come to expect
on monday night check out dana perino
chris wallace people liked michelle
obama's speech on fox news
over the course of the night the first
virtual convention of our history
i think they would say that michelle
obama stuck the landing chris wallace
your thoughts
well i agree with dana you know it's
interesting michelle obama
as she said doesn't like politics and uh
she said that this speech was her main
contribution
to the biden campaign it was a heck of a
contribution
she really flayed uh sliced and diced
donald trump
talking about the chaos and confusion
and lack of empathy especially
coming from this president and from this
white house spoke more about
the deficits of donald trump than the
pluses of joe biden
but did talk about especially not so
much policies but especially
his empathy what he's been through and
his care for average american she said
we have to vote
so what do we make of this is this some
major reversal where fox news is no
longer right wing
and uh no longer supporting trump and
fox news
now supports democrats no no no no not
not even in the slightest
uh it's a very instructive example
to understand a little bit about how
corporate media works in the united
states
fox news offers theatrics and hyperbole
from a right-wing perspective for profit
and the for-profit part
is a big piece of the analysis so think
back to early
in the 2016 republican primary which
started in 2015 really
the role of fox news was we cover trump
being kooky but we oppose him because
we're a serious right-wing network and
we support people like you know whoever
the buttoned-up right-winger was at the
time was it jeb or was it
you know ted cruz or whatever it doesn't
matter trump then wins the primary
then fox news falls in line and gets
behind donald trump because they're not
going to get behind hillary clinton
hillary's bad
obama's bad they get behind trump and it
is a
business decision fundamentally and a
decision about if trump is president i
mean he's the nominee if he's president
we want access to trump
trump becomes president and is
completely outrageous as president
so fox news actually sort of does a dr
jekyll and mr hyde
sort of thing the opinion people remain
solidly behind trump carrying water for
him you know sean hannity
janine pirro laura ingram tucker carlson
mostly
uh the fox and friends people who i know
that's supposedly a news show come on
guys that's an opinion show
but they do want to gin up controversy
and kind of play all sides
so when shep smith still worked at the
network he would sometimes call out
trump for his obvious lies or
chris wallace will confront trump during
interviews or whatever the case may be
okay now we find ourselves in a
situation where it's unclear if donald
trump is going to win so
fox is running parallel narratives again
for profit this is what explains the
entire
sort of status quo at fox news hannity
and the opinion people
are mostly still behind trump if trump
wins
trump will still be there for them and
they'll be there for trump if donald
trump is reelected
if trump loses fox is laying out a
little bit of the groundwork they're
laying a little pipe so to speak
to say we're objective we criticize
trump or praised democrats like michelle
obama's speech when it made sense
and the point is to be positioned after
november for any eventuality to maintain
access to people in positions of power
period now
you might be wondering does do fox
executives pull chris wallace aside and
go listen chris
we need you to praise michelle obama and
really be tough on trump
so that we can do this plan no that's
not the way it works it's much the same
way as you know
rt anchors will often say
i actually haven't seen rt in years but
years ago i don't even know if it's
still on tv in the us honestly but
but years ago rt anchors would say i've
never been
told what to say on the air in terms of
russian narratives or whatever no that's
not the way it works right
you are selected because you have been
hired
in a role right you you you uh are
choosing the people
that on their own will play the roles
that you are trying to fill and it's
much the same thing on fox news so i
don't believe it's calculated in that
chris wallace needs to be told what to
do chris wallace just needs to be put in
positions to do what chris wallace does
and that's how they build the narrative
so
the bottom line is money that's really
it the murdoch family isn't stupid
the big goal is be in line with
conservative governments
be friendly with right wing governments
around the world
if they can help the right retain its
power
then they will swing some support to
whoever
uh is likely to win and that's the
strategy
if it looks like the right will lose
power
then they will put a little bit of
support just enough
behind whoever is likely to win so that
when that person wins be it joe biden or
were it hillary clinton in in 2016 they
can
maintain access and they can kind of
create a responsibility from the winner
to still treat fox news seriously
because that's how fox news continues to
sort of
replicate itself and perpetuate itself
this is business 101
you might notice there's no journalism
analysis here
this is not a communications uh analysis
where you would understand you know in a
in a theoretical academic communication
class
about uh anything related to journalism
or media this is business
this is what you would learn in business
school and if you try to evaluate this
as
journalism um the commentary
makes no sense if you see this through
the lens of business
then it makes perfect sense and that's
exactly what this is
for fox news don't be tricked into
thinking that it's anything else
we'll have more coverage of this on the
show's instagram
david pakman show on instagram and while
you're there you can follow me on
instagram
at david.pacman as well
one of our sponsors is surf shark which
is a vpn service that
i trust to protect me online and they're
giving my audience
eighty-five percent off a two-year plan
this comes out to under two bucks a
month
plus you'll get three extra months for
free if you don't already use a vpn
you should really start because it
protects you from being spied on by
governments
uh protects you from internet service
providers who sell your data
tech companies that track you online
surf shark is a vpn you can trust
because unlike many other vpns they
don't monitor your internet activity or
keep any record of it it hides your ip
address
it encrypts all your data keeps you safe
from
hackers and will even block ads and
protect you from viruses
and the best part is you can install it
on unlimited
devices i use it anytime i'm connected
to the internet
surf shark is giving my audience 85 off
a two-year plan which comes out to
less than two bucks a month plus you'll
get three extra months for free
go to surfshark.deals
pacman the link is right underneath this
video